eye exercises will improve your vision
can i just do this please yes
contact lenses can get lost behind your
eye
uh no if you sneeze with your eyes open
they'll pop out i i don't know where to
start with this um myth hi my name is dr
ronnie banik i'm a board certified
ophthalmologist and
neuro-ophthalmologist and i'm dr
jennifer sci practicing optometrist in
new york city i specialize in medical
and aesthetic eye care and today we will
be debunking myths about vision 2020
means you have perfect vision ah that's
a good one a lot of people think 2020
means perfect vision but there is so
much to vision beyond just reading the
eye chart and reading down to 2020. and
when we say 2020 vision it means that
this chart is at 20 feet away from the
patient and they can read all the way
down to this line right here there are
other lines below that some people can
actually read even better than 2020 but
there are so many other components of
vision for example there's color vision
there's peripheral vision there's
contrast and we also check for near
point vision which has to do with
reading up close and technically you
could have 20 20 vision but have a
condition such as glaucoma which can
cause peripheral vision loss which means
you have perfect 20 20 vision in the
center but you might have side vision
loss blue light will damage my eyes oh
my gosh i don't know what to think about
that back in 2018 there was a study that
came out that the media picked up on and
they said oh blue light is going to
damage your retina it's going to cause
permanent blindness what the researchers
did in the study was they took cells
they put them in a petri dish and they
exposed those cells to high high levels
of blue light and they found out that
those cells died the truth is that the
cells that they put in that petri dish
were not even eye cells they were
cervical cancer cells so our retina
cells have pigments that protect us
against blue light they're called lutein
and zeaxanthin they're like our natural
blue blockers and they protect our eyes
against blue light so there is no proof
that blue light damages your eyes and if
it were really true we would actually
have a pandemic of blindness because all
of us are on devices all the time
children adults and it's just not true
we do know that it affects our sleep and
it does cause insomnia because it
changes our circadian rhythm so when you
wear like coating on your glasses it
does help with light sensitivity and
glare and just generally making you feel
more comfortable when you're doing work
so there is no downside to it the tint
does make a difference because if you
put on the lighter tint blue blockers
and if you look at your screen if you
can still see the color blue it means
that that blue blocker is not blocking
out 100 of the blue light maybe it's
blocking out a certain lower percentage
maybe 30 to 40 percent versus if you put
on these these are the super duper blue
blockers if you look at a screen with
these on
you don't see any blue whatsoever so for
example if i'm having trouble sleeping
and i need to use my computer at night
i'll wear these at night time two hours
before bed so it doesn't really
interfere with my sleep the other thing
that can happen when you're on a screen
for a long time is probably you're not
blinking enough so you're probably also
getting dry eye and that's probably also
contributing to the eye strain you will
lose your vision as you age i hear this
all the time for my patients i have
patients who are older your 60s 70s 80s
even 90 year old patients who still have
20 20 vision sometimes the dinner menu
gets harder to read at the restaurant
and i tell them that's absolutely normal
that's not losing your vision it's just
that our vision starts to change in the
other direction sometimes so when we're
referring to presbyopia that is the
gradual change when our eyes are not
able to accommodate or focus on near
objects as well and we tend to hold
things further back so why does this
happen well it's because inside the eye
we have a lens now normally the lens is
very flexible and it can change shape
sometimes it can get thicker or thinner
in the middle that allows us to focus at
different distances as we get older
though this lens just doesn't change
shape as well it becomes more stiff and
when it becomes more stiff that is
called loss of accommodation or
presbyopia and again that usually
happens to most people sometime in their
40s or 50s we also notice that over time
our eyes start to improve as we get
older it has to do with the fact that as
we grow our eyes elongate and that can
lead to myopia or near-sightedness and
over time just like our body can shrink
our eyes can shrink shorter and that can
lead our prescription to go the opposite
way there's lots that can go wrong but
as long as you see your eye doctor
regularly you get checked for it you get
it taken care of you can still maintain
good 20 20 vision into your golden years
lasik means no glasses forever i wish
that were true but there is no guarantee
with any kind of procedure that your
vision will be what you hope it to be
lasik is just resetting your
prescription back to zero so lasik can
provide sharp clear vision but that
doesn't mean it can prevent myopia
regression or the need for reading
glasses sometimes there can be
regression which means that after six
months or a year the cornea may start to
change back into its natural shape for
the most part it is very very safe but
just make sure you talk to your surgeon
about it first to make sure that you're
a good candidate because not everyone is
a good candidate
okay color blindness equals seeing in
black and white this is an interesting
one a lot of people think that if you
have color blindness that's all you're
going to see is like monochrome but it's
not true most people who have color
blindness or what we call color
deficiency have issues with seeing
different shades of reds and greens and
sometimes also oranges and yellows it's
not that they can't see those colors
they just see those colors differently
so we have cells in our retinas called
photoreceptors the rods are responsible
for light and dark vision the cones are
responsible for color visions we have
red cones green cones and blue cones and
these cones are all tuned into certain
wavelengths so in people who are color
blind it's not that they don't have
those cones it's just that those cones
are set to a different wavelength so
instead of seeing a red is bright red
they may see it kind of as a muted color
or maybe as like an orange or yellow
actually it's pretty common in the
population to have color blindness i
think it's like eight percent of the
population if you go to the eye doctor
they can do a color test on you it shows
you numbers within patterns of color
and it tests the intensity or density of
how much colorblindness there is over a
spectrum but it really doesn't impact
someone's life at all people with
colorblindness function completely
normally and there is no long-term issue
with that eye exercises will improve
your vision what do you think about that
this is a myth can i just do this please
yes
so there is just so much misinformation
out there when it comes to eye exercises
many people think that if they do
certain exercises that will help them
decrease their myopia or their hyperopia
or their astigmatism i wish that were
true but there is no truth to that our
eyes are shaped in a certain way our
corneas are shaped a certain way the
length of the eye is a certain way and
what you do in terms of exercises will
not change that so it is probably one of
the biggest myths out there you may have
heard of the 20 20 20 rule which is
every 20 minutes take a 20 second break
to look at something 20 feet away and
really the whole goal of that is just to
allow your eyes to relax often to the
distance so that does help relieve a
little bit of that strain but it
certainly isn't something that corrects
for your vision there is one condition
where eye exercises can help it's a
condition called convergence
insufficiency where if we're looking at
something up close for a long time the
eyes get fatigued and start to drift out
a little bit so there is one exercise
called pencil push-ups where people can
help strengthen those muscles and help
them focus longer and not feel that
fatigue maybe it'll prevent them from
seeing double but it won't actually
change the power or the refraction of
the eye i think the best way to improve
your vision is simply to go to the eye
doctor find out what the issue is and
get it taken care of wearing glasses
will make your vision worse i get this
all the time for my patients like doctor
really do i need to wear these glasses
isn't it going to make things worse the
truth is no what happens is when people
are seeing blurry they wear their
glasses and then they see clearly but
then they take their glasses off all of
a sudden they're saying blurry again
wearing them or not wearing them does
not cause progression the change has
more to do with genetics and just
natural axial elongation of your eyeball
so an analogy i like to use with my
patients is let's say you hurt your
ankle and you can't walk properly so use
a crutch it's going to help you but it's
not actually going to worsen your ankle
so if your eye doctor thinks you need
glasses or contacts and prescribes them
for you it's for your benefit it will
help you see better so please wear them
dry eyes aren't very serious that's a
tricky one most of the time dry eyes
might not be serious but it could cause
potential issues that lead to scarring
on the cornea
i would say 80 percent of the population
might deal some sort of dryness in fact
children are experiencing at a much
younger age we're noticing that
statistically speaking about 125 million
people ages 18 to
50 experience dryness but they don't
report it or do anything for it so if
you can imagine when we are looking at
our phones or reading a book we tend to
just stare and that means our blink rate
decreases by at least a half so we lose
our blink completeness and over time our
tears can evaporate much much quicker
but when you go see your eye doctor
usually they'll use different dyes or
colored strips or that can help to stain
the cornea to see exactly how much
dryness you have and where the dryness
is and there are actually ways to also
image the glands the truth is you really
need to use the drops very often it's
not just once a day you need to use them
multiple times during the day dry eyes
like dry skin so lubricate frequently
it's okay to get generic as long as you
look at the ingredients and there's no
ingredient called polyvinyl alcohol if
you see anything with alcohol in there
please don't buy it because that can
actually irritate your eyes even more
it's not fully ph balanced to your eye
it could actually make things worse in
most cases dry eyes are not serious but
sometimes they can be so don't let it
get to that level where it becomes
serious if you sneeze with your eyes
open
they'll pop out i'll let you take it
yeah
i i don't know where to start with this
myth
there's a certain condition that can
cause proptosis which is the bulging of
the eyes though it's rare it just has to
do with the elasticity of the lid itself
if you have more relaxed lids and the
eyes when you sneeze it can pop out a
bit but certainly they don't fall out
you don't have to search for them on the
floor or anything like that we actually
have in our eye socket it's a really
intricate network of muscles and
connective tissue that keep the eye in
its place so you can see that there's
one two
three there's some on the bottom four
and then there's two others in the back
so there's six eye muscles behind each
eye these eye muscles are connected to
the back of the eye socket they hold
everything in place so there is no way
that the eye could actually come out of
the eye socket it's a good thing our
eyes actually automatically close when
we sneeze as a natural reflex and it has
to do with our body's way
to really expel what it thinks is an
issue or bacteria so it's probably
impossible to sneeze with your eyes open
so just let your body do its thing
contact lenses can get lost behind your
eye
uh no definitely a myth because you have
a protective barrier called the
conjunctiva it's to prevent things from
getting dislodged back there i've had a
patient who came in and she kept
thinking that the contact lens got lost
or it fell out and when she came in the
third or fourth time i saw that she had
four contact lenses on her cornea and
that's because she thought it fell out
but it was still on there but she just
kept putting in a fresh pair every
single time all you really have to do is
just make sure you blink a few times put
in some artificial tears to get that
contact lens to loosen up and eventually
it should come out and you should be
able to find it and pull it out of the
eye most of the time i notice that
patients just actually rub their eyes in
the contact lens falls out and they
think that it's so back in the eye and
when i check it's not there that's
happened to me yeah
sunglasses aren't necessary myth
total myth you do need sunglasses
because we always want to protect our
retina and our macula our lens and our
cornea so these are mine um do you have
yours i do i have mine
i'll go ahead put them on honestly they
make you look fashionable and cool while
protecting your eyes at the same time we
are constantly exposed to sunlight
exposure even on cloudy days and when
that happens even though the progression
might be slow it can put our eyes at
risk in the future for other issues or
long-term consequences the uva and uvb
rays are so powerful they can burn their
cornea they can burn your retina they
can lead to growths on the surface of
the eye they can even lead to eye
cancers or eyelid cancers here are some
tips for sunglasses all sunglasses are
not made the same darker does not always
mean better so you want to make sure the
label says 100 uva uvb protection or it
might say absorption up to 400
nanometers you also want to make sure
that you go for oversized or even one
that wraps around because you actually
are constantly exposed to sunlight from
top and from the sides things like
polarized lints doesn't always equal
more uv protection same thing like
mirror lenses or tinted lenses yeah they
can definitely help they can cut the
glare especially if you're skiing or out
in the water snowboarding etc but you
want to get the uv protection in
addition to the polarization or the tint
floaters are always harmless
floaters are actually very very common
but they're not always harmless there
are a lot of different structures inside
the eye but this structure here it's
clear plastic but inside the eye it's
actually a jelly called the vitreous
that helps to keep the shape of the eye
so it doesn't just collapse but this
jelly is made out of lots of different
things water and collagen and hyaluronic
acid as we get older the jelly instead
of being firm like jello starts to break
down and when it breaks down into more
of a liquid form we start to see little
pieces of collagen floating around
inside of it and these little pieces of
collagen you know when light comes in
through the front of the eye it hits
those little collagen strands and
creates a shadow on the retina and
that's what we see as a floater i think
it's estimated that about 80 percent of
people have floaters in most cases
they're benign but sometimes they can be
associated with more serious eye
conditions if you have a shower of new
floaters it may be an indicator that
you're developing a retinal tear or
retinal detachment which is really an
emergency you really need to get that
checked out right away or sometimes
people have floaters because they have
inflammation inside the eye and that
usually is associated with blurred
vision flashes of light sometimes pain
or redness definitely get it checked out
if they're new if you've never had
floaters before two blue-eyed parents
can't have a brown-eyed kid that's a
great one genetics is a complicated
topic and even though you think that
blue eyes are recessive and if you have
two blue-eyed parents they're guaranteed
to have a blue-eyed child it's not
always the case there's a particular
gene called oca2 it helps determine if
someone's eye colors can be brown or
blue but there are different ways the
gene expresses itself so sometimes the
gene is truly dominant but sometimes
only partially dominant so there's a lot
that goes into determining a baby's eye
color but definitely it is possible not
common but it is possible for two blue
eyed parents to have a brown eyed child
and also babies when they're born they
tend to have lighter eye colors and then
usually over the first couple of years
of life usually by the age of two that
color may darken to its ultimate final
colors the pigment migrates into the
iris sometimes it takes a while for that
pigment to fully migrate and then fully
kind of settle use your eyes when you
first wake up to when you go to sleep so
you want to protect it by making sure
you wear sunglasses keep your eyes
lubricated and to wear your correction
and so definitely start early you know
eat healthy exercise see your eye doctor
if you do all these things you can
hopefully maintain healthy vision for a
lifetime you want to be proactive about
it and prevent it from happening